from the Associated Press 61 indicted in
Georgia on racketeering charges
connected to stop cop City movement I
love this stuff they say 61 people have
been indicted in Georgia on racketeering
charges in the sweeping indictment
release Tuesday Republican attorney
general Chris Carr interestingly
interesting alleged the defendants are
militant anarchists who supported a
violent movement that prosecutors Trace
to the widespread 2020 racial Justice
protests the August 29 indictment is the
latest application of the state's
anti-racketeering law also known as a
RICO law that comes just after Fulton
County prosecutor used the statute to
charge former president Donald Trump and
18 other defendants the stop Cap City
effort has gone on for more than two
years and at times veered into vandalism
and violence opponents fear the training
center will lead to greater military
militarization of the police and that
its construction in an urban Forest will
exacerbate environmental damage in the
poor majority black area I love that
qualifier that defense of these far left
extremists let me just pull up that
there Wikipedia entry on stop cop City
and it's a domestic Terror charges 20
people in all we're here with these
charges going back to January and
December
on March 6 it was reported 23 people had
thrown large rocks bricks Molotov
cocktails and through fireworks at
police as well as having set buildings
and equipment on fire had been charged
with domestic terrorism only two of them
were from Atlanta one was from France
and one was from Canada but thank you AP
for adding that needless caveat or not
caveat but a qualifier that they're
worried it will it will make
environmental damage worse in this poor
majority black area this is the issue
when it comes to the left when it comes
to the right even when you get serious
criminal charges now 81 it appears the
media will do everything to protect them
take a look at this from NPR domestic
terrorism charges in Georgia are
prompting concern over political
repression and they start the story by
saying when Luke Harper went to Atlanta
in early March he thought he would be
staying the weekend a 27 year old
copywriter for Florida was just going to
go there to join demonstration and
opposite of the police but on second
night after attending a music festival
with other protesters he was arrested
and accused of being a domestic
terrorist maybe it was like I don't know
when that dude opened fire on police I
think more than one and the cops shot
back and one of them died or when they
went around burning buildings but this
is what you get right now the other big
news which we'll get into in a second is
that Enrique tario who was not even at
January 6 has been sentenced to 22 years
in prison and what do you think the
media is saying about him
well they're definitely going to call
him a domestic terrorist I mean the the
contrast between the treatment between
of these two groups or two types of
people is insane uh it's impossible not
to see it as uh inflammatory and and
attempt to try and push differences I
mean yes the AP has an article about
this but it's not being picked up the
same way so few people know about what's
going on in Georgia I mean I honestly
think Tim you're one of the people who
talk about it the most and that's crazy
because it's a year-long essentially uh
sit in protest that's all that has
repeatedly come to Violence January 6
while complicated and obviously made him
a national impression was one day and
did not cause nearly the destruction
that this is happening to to Fulton
County so I just don't understand it
it's interesting I think you know a lot
of people are celebrating the indictment
but this came from uh I think this
indictment is coming from the state
level not from the local level and it's
unsurprising that you know the Atlanta
area which is left-leaning Democrat
isn't doing anything for for the most
part and it's the state level government
and I'm curious I don't know exactly
where this goes I will say I am
surprised and shocked that any charges
came about but then again Georgia is a
weirdly
I don't how do you describe it it's it's
a red state right kind of
it's red but it has a uh several major
Democratic strongholds and it's uh right
it's a more interesting and like
demographically complicated State than a
lot of red states which are like you
know majority white or something like
that uh it really is it makes sense that
it's a Battleground State because it's
it's in conflict with itself as much as
it is with many other across the U.S
it's I think it's always good to just
take it back to the point like these
people are going to get maybe a few
years behind bars if that you know uh
it's a slap on the wrist and they're
literally committing this domestic
terrorism they're treasonous maybe even
and look at that they get a few years
but they're trying to lock up Julian
Assange for the rest of his life
Julian Assange thing is an assassination
yeah right yeah and with this antiva
thing they've not even been sentenced
these are charges don't be surprised if
like in DC on it was the January 20th
2017 protests yes they criminally
charged 200 some odd people with
conspiracy and it was a big like oh oh
heavens and that would happen they all
got acquitted charges were dropped and
then they were paid millions of dollars
in a lawsuit so we're seeing this now
but at the same time the inverse story
is about people who are being rated this
is the crazy thing they're starting to
raid more people over January 6. they
were waiting for an election year so
yeah and then you know to your point
Julian Assange oh boy yeah I mean look
Julie Assange is a real threat to the
established order Julian Assange did
everything appropriately and as unless
any information has been kept secret I
can only see him doing journalistic
activities and that is really damaging
so what do they do oh they lock him up
and they they essentially try to let's
just say they silenced him right
what these these lunatics are doing in
Atlanta is just chaos they've killed
people they they've killed people I mean
this in Atlanta they killed people you
said they've shot they've uh they shot a
cop the cop didn't die okay well they've
shot more bullets at Americans than
Putin's Army has we'll leave it at that
all right fair point I mean that's true
but you hear nothing about it hold on
hold on actually there are Americans on
the ground fighting in Ukraine so they
are getting shot at by Putin's forces
yeah but they're not like I guess
declared us they're not there doing
official business of the US yeah I don't
think that matters to be honest like
like the US intentionally has people
there is intentionally engaging in this
conflict what do you mean they're not in
war with Ukraine we're just sending them
tons of money and Military Support yeah
and intelligence and volunteers and
weapons for those volunteers and
training for those volunteers well we
love service in this country we think
it's great to help other people uh I I
think the antifa story is so interesting
because
this is sort of the heaviest hit that
I've seen to antifa I mean Portland
cannot get their situation under control
and in contrast it's the same day that
we see the longest sentence hand down to
anyone involved in anything related to
January 6. I mean if you can't see that
the justice system has favorites I don't
know what we'll tell you uh I don't I
don't know
how people can have faith in any sort of
uh judicial branch of if state or
whatever or anything I mean the federal
government is sending thousands of
people they've charged thousands of
people I think it's a thousand 106 the
last doj number I saw uh in connection
January 6th uh 600 people at least have
been sentenced and in contrast you know
Justin Jones who's a state
representative in Tennessee got
reinstated after he led a you know
protest on the floor of the chamber that
disrupted official official proceedings
I assume that's also a form of
Statistics conspiracy but Tennessee has
not gone after him for that I mean well
it just shows that like there are some
things that we are willing to let slip
by depending on what you're promoting I
I do want to give a shout out to
Christopher Carr of Georgia because it's
funny because you know our executive
editor his name's Chris Carr but he was
absent last week he was on vacation I
wonder what he was up to maybe he's
actually Moonlighting as the Georgia uh
attorney general no but we often talk
about how it's like we we see not a
single Republican or conservative do
anything as the left runs rampant
firebombing well he is he is shout out
now I mean B minus C plus right it's
good that these Psychopaths who are
firebombing buildings burning them down
flipping over Vehicles shooting at cops
it's good they're being criminally
charged and is going after them with
some like he's going after these Rico
good they conspire they plan these
things there's the crazy video of like a
hundred plus people I hope he gets all
of them to rest all of them there is a
difference however I I don't I don't
much care for a like Tit for Tat in the
sense that you know in Georgia they
indict Donald Trump the front runner for
the Republican party and then you get a
guy saying oh yeah I'm gonna arrest some
extremists who are at this this cop
thing I'm like those are totally
different territories I'm still glad
that it's happening it's not exactly
whatever everyone is asking for when it
comes to corruption you've got Democrats
who have complained about the election
who lobbied election officials who
begged people to vote for for somebody
else who claimed Trump was a Russian spy
that's the dishes conspiracy when you
have Hillary Clinton you know uh
effectively I I correct him I'm wrong
but funding the steel dossier resulting
in a fine and a bunch of other things I
mean that's seditious conspiracy
accusing the president of being a spy to
try and win election that is stealing
power trying to I guess the only
argument is Trump wasn't in office at
the time
and uh and Joe Biden was but the problem
is we see all of that and there's no
action being taken against any of the
Democrats who are in office who are
pushing the stuff
yeah it seems one step at a time I
suppose the I'm with you I I'm glad that
these violent protesters are facing
Justice
um but I am concerned yeah you could
call it that a violent protest Riot
these people that were shooting
terrorist cops yeah for sure and uh but
what concerns me a little bit is that
it's uh I think you mentioned Tit for
Tat that the bar is getting raised like
okay now we've decided it's okay to
charge someone with 80 counts of this
now we're gonna go with someone over
there okay because like you said earlier
there's the left to the right and the
establishment The Establishment don't
care what side of the culture War you're
on it will use that side's justification
to go after that side and then that
side's justification to go back after
that site and then happily stay on top
of the hill so I don't like this this
escalation of lawfare but it you know
the guys that are shooting at cops they
need to go it is law fair but the last
thing I'll say is that like you said the
people that have committed all these war
crimes in Syria or in wherever you know
they're they're never going to be held
accountable those are The Untouchables
I'm pretty sure Obama won an award
called the Peace Prize yeah and you know
he blew up kids he's such a air-striking
uh you know wedding processions all that
stuff yeah here's here's an important
piece of the AP news that y'all are
gonna love
you see among those charts domestic
terrorism in March near the music
festival and indicted last week as
Thomas Jurgens the Southern Poverty Law
Center staff attorney jurgen's lawyer
said his client wore a bright green hat
a Wellman identifier used by legal
observers and his arrest alarmed many
human rights organizations the Law
Center called an example of heavy-handed
law enforcement intervention against
protesters DeKalb County district
attorney Sherry Boston a Democrat
mentioned her concerns about jurgen's
prosecution in announcing her June
decision to withdraw from criminal cases
connected to the movement listen my
friends
just explain to me where you think this
country is currently at when when the
Democrat district attorney outright says
they are not going to prosecute or or be
involved in criminal cases against
terrorists
and Fulton County is trying to indict
the front runner for the for their rival
political party and his lawyers
just call whatever you want I don't care
literally no but uh yo something crazy
is going on
something absolutely insane is happening
when you have 81 people being charged
another conspiracy or domestic Terror by
a Republican and a Democrat being like
I'm not going to be involved in any of
those criminal charges like these people
shut it cops and then they're like the
January 6th should be rounded up and my
guitar gets 22 years in person dude
wasn't even there wasn't even there well
in the majority whatever you want of the
of the people arrested are out of state
in Georgia and for stop cop city right
so George was literally under attack
from people who are not from Georgia and
their attorney general is like no it's
fine I'm not interested in taking part
yeah what is this domestic they call it
domestic terrorism but if a guy from
France comes to the United States and
commits a Act of terrorism that's not
domestic domestic means that they are
Americans attacking America so this is a
french guy and a Canadian guy yeah
apparently so it's just straight up
International terrorism these guys came
to the United States to wreak havoc on
cops that's that's yeah what was
happening in like in in Hungary or some
other country you know they'd be sending
in Victoria Newland to go and like
launch a coup and install a new
government we're literally living in a
Banana Republic right now thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows elusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time